hot breath your approach to the work of
comedy
is inspiring and like you're talking
about oh i'll just write for five hours
a day because seinfeld said but
i mean i've gone through phases where
i'm like i'm writing every day and this
is great and then it's like you miss one
day and then one day turns into a week
and then a week turns into a month and
then it's a year
and you're like wait where'd my writing
habit go like exactly what kind of tips
do you have
for comedians to start that daily ritual
we all know we should do
and we all feel better when we write but
it there
seems to be a block with us just staying
consistent you know
well i think that's with everybody and
everything like if you're uh
like if you're old arnold schwarzenegger
or the rock
he's in the gym every day that's what he
does it's like his religion it's
non-negotiable
and when i decided i was going to write
it was going to be non-negotiable i had
to get every day i had to
be in that seat and it was like i know
comedians who have a day job
who adhere more to the schedule of that
day job that they hate than they do to
their writing schedule because they
impose it upon themselves
and i think there's a couple of blocks
there one is a lot of comedians get in
to
equate comedy with frivolity and
therefore they treat their careers
frivolously
and so it's like well i kind of got into
this to beat the system
you know so why would i adhere to a
system if i don't want to be in a system
and comedy serious business man when
you're making 40
your minimum pay is 4 000 a week writing
a on a late show
then it's worth it's you better work
your butt off if you want that job it's
it's harder than
you think um but you know so if i get up
every day
and my that my day is basically i i make
my coffee i sit down with my laptop
open it up at the kitchen table and i'll
say okay i'm gonna look for ten
i'm gonna look for i'm gonna start with
three headline jokes
and then i'll just take three headlines
and with those three headline jokes i'll
usually write
say 15 jokes per headline
and that that gets me started okay and
so then um
and that'll be uh then i'll be like an
hour and a half in or something like
that and then i'll write some more
and i might get inspired to go off on a
different place
sometimes i sit down and i go okay today
i'm gonna do
i assign myself like on a certain day so
i'll assign myself today's cliche
reformations
so i'm just gonna grab 10 random cliches
that everybody's familiar with
and that can include book titles movie
titles
slogans for corporations i'll just write
those down
and say okay i'm going to write some
takeoffs and some reformations
so a reformation is taking the first
part of the
cliche and then coming up with the
second ending right so
uh it's like wc fields if at first you
don't succeed
our brains are running try try again and
all you
all he says is quit there's no use
killing yourself over it so
finding a cliche and finding a second
ending so then i'll do a few of those
and that'll just if i do one also i'm
inspired
because there's some days you wake up
you don't you don't feel like it exactly
and so
if i do one or two of those i'll be like
wow i'm feeling like it now i feel
inspired because i came up with one joke
one joke can change your whole viewpoint
of how you feel about writing today
you just have to show up every day you
just force yourself and
we're talking about a five hour habit
but would you start off like okay i'm
just gonna sit down and write
one joke every day and then it like
grows into oh i wrote one now i feel
like writing five more
like you just kind of yeah it started
with goals type deal
in fact that's what gene parrott said to
me sit down write one joke a day next
week change it to three jokes a day next
week
double it go to six jokes a day because
if you could write three you could write
six
it was tough when i started hitting 18
then 30
and i was like i'm tap tapped he goes
push yourself and i got past 30 to 60
and then then also it just grew
and every threshold i hit and passed it
i knew if i could pass that one i could
pass this one and so it sort of became
like uh
trying to be a an athlete towards your
writing you know i'm gonna push myself
further and if you're not sitting down
every day
pushing yourself to get better you're
not improving
we see comics do this all the time they
plateau and they sort of stay the same
with no reinventing or no new
discoveries
as comics they're just the same you know
so it's like
how are they how do they expect to get
better if they're not doing anything to
improve
are you improving the amount of mics
you're doing per week are you improving
the amount of jokes you're writing are
you trying to come up with fresh stuff
are you replacing the mundane jokes that
get mediocre laughs
with laughs that get you know real
punches and applause breaks
if you're not effectively doing that
you're not really doing anything to get
better
it's pushing yourself past your comfort
zone so
that's uh that's kind of what i try to
do